one of the leading contenders for
coronavirus vaccine has started a final
round of testing in the united states
researchers at oxford university in
partnership with astrazeneca started
dosing the first volunteers in florida
on friday
31 people have received either the
vaccine or a placebo
doctor john lepucc has been covering the
search for this cobit vaccine good
morning to you again john lepuc
so what happens in phase three of this
trial
good morning yet again gail during the
third and final phase the vaccines
tested for safety
and how effective it is at reducing or
blocking covert 19 symptoms
that's before getting fda approval for
public use
i spoke exclusively with the first
american in the oxford astrazeneca trial
look at the amount of lives that we lost
and i just don't
want that to keep occurring 23 year old
jacob serrano is the first volunteer to
be dosed in the u.s with either the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine or a placebo
he has lost seven family members to
covet 19 and says he wants to be part of
the solution to save lives
no matter the cost i knew there was a
risk because it's like it's a trial
but i'd rather have us one step closer
no matter what it takes
serrano was dosed on friday at headlands
gem research institute in lake worth
florida
immune response was very encouraging dr
larry bush is an infectious disease
doctor and the lead principal
investigator for this trial site
he says he's optimistic this vaccine is
effective in the phase
one and two trials the vaccine has been
proven that not only do you get
robust neutralizing antibodies to fight
the
coronavirus you get a t cell response
another arm of the immune system
to fight off the cells that do become
infected that's crucial in treating
infections
oxford university has been conducting
phase three trials in the united kingdom
brazil and south africa in earlier
phases there was no evidence the vaccine
causes serious reactions
headlands research says their focus is
on enrolling members of the african
american and the latinx community
who have been disproportionately
affected by the pandemic
the numbers are pointing to that those
groups of people becoming infected at a
higher
rate and therefore that's a group that
would highly benefit from
vaccination astrazeneca says it plans to
enroll
up to 50 000 participants globally and
is planning to start phase 3 trials in
japan
and russia the company expects to have
late stage trial results
later this year gail we hope so dr lupu
what's the significance of enrolling
participants from all around the world
for this
well a couple of things gail you want to
have a diverse population of people who
are being tested but also you want to be
in areas where there's a there are a lot
of cases
the more cases there are in an area the
more quickly you'll find out whether the
vaccine works whether there's a
difference between giving the placebo
and giving the vaccine i mean think
about it if you give it in an area where
there are no cases there'll be
absolutely no difference between people
getting the placebo
and the vaccine and this is one reason
why we don't know exactly when phase
three trials are going to
give us statistically significant
results because it depends on how
effective the vaccine is and how many
cases there are in the area being tested
yeah we will all want a vaccine but more
than anything we want it to be safe
so is this being tested for kit on kids
and how safe is it for children if it is
being tested on kids
you know gail kids are not being tested
yet and the definition of a kid is
anybody under
18. but what happens is that
once there's some signal of efficacy of
effectiveness of the vaccine in the
adult trials
then they can go back and they can start
doing safety trials
in children and then if those go well
they can actually look at the efficacy
trials those results in adults
as a sort of a bridge to getting a
vaccine approved
to children there are a lot of steps in
the way of that but that's basically
what's been explained to me about the
process so no children are being given
it right now
but in the future that could happen
thank you john